let's explore a bit the infinite series
from n equals 1 to infinity of 1
over n squared which of course is equal
to 1
plus
1 4 that's 1 over 2 squared plus 1 over
3 squared which is 1 9 plus 1 16 and it
goes on and on and on forever so there's
a couple of things that we know about it
the first thing is all of the terms here
are positive
so all of the terms here are positive
so
they're all positive and that they're
decreasing they're it looks like they're
they're decreasing quite quickly here
from 1 to 1 4th to 1 9 to 1 16 and so
they're quickly approaching zero which
makes us feel pretty good that this
thing may only has a has a chance of
converging and because they're all
positive we know that this sum right
over here if it does converge is going
to be greater than zero so the reason
the only reason why it wouldn't converge
is if somehow it goes unbounded towards
infinity which we know if this was one
over n it would be unbounded towards
infinity so this says
that's that's a possibility here so if
we could show that this is bounded then
that'll be a pretty good argument for
why this thing right over here converges
because the only reason why you could
diverge is if you went to either
positive infinity or negative infinity
we already know that this thing isn't
going to go to negative infinity because
it's all positive terms or you could
diverge if this thing oscillates but
it's not going to oscillate because all
of these terms are just adding to the
sum none of them are taking away none of
because none of these terms are negative
so let's see if we can make up make a
good argument for why this sum right
over here is bounded and especially if
we can come up with the bound then
that's a pretty good argument for this
that that this infinite series should
converge
and the way that we're going to do that
is we're going to explore a related
function
so what i want to do is i want to
explore f of x
is equal to 1 over x squared
you could really view this right over
here 1 over n squared as f of
n if if i were to write it this way
so why is this interesting well let's
graph it
let's graph it
so that's the graph of y is equal to f
of x
y is equal to f of x
and notice this is a continuous positive
decreasing function especially over the
interval that i've or over over the
interval that i care about right over
here i guess we could say over the for
for positive values of x it is a
continuous
where it is a continuous positive
decreasing function and what's
interesting is we can use this
as
really an underestimate for this area
right over here what do i mean by that
well
one this first term right over here
you could view that as the area of this
block right over here
that is f of f of n or i guess you could
say f of 1 high and 1 wide so it's going
to be 1 it's going to be 1 times 1 over
1 squared or 1.
this term
this let me make sure i'm using
different colors this term right over
here that could represent the area
of this
block
which is one fourth high and one wide so
it is going to be it's going to have an
area of one-fourth
what could this one represent well the
area of the next block if we're trying
to estimate the area under the curve and
this might look familiar from when we
first got exposed to the integral or
even before we got exposed to the
integral we're taking riemann sums so
that right over here that area is going
to be equal to 1 9.
so what's intriguing about this is we
know how to find
the exact area especially or the exact
area from 1 to infinity from x equals 1
to infinity so maybe we can use that
somehow
we know what this area is right over
here for which we can denote as
the improper integral from 1 to infinity
of f of x dx we know what that is and
i'll figure out in a little bit and if
we know what this is if we can figure
out the value that's going to be an
upper bound for 1 4 plus 1 9 plus 1 16
on and on and on and so that will allow
us to essentially bound what this series
evaluates to and as
as we said earlier that would be a very
good argument for its convergence so the
whole point here i'm not doing a
rigorous proof but really getting you
the the underlying conceptual
understanding for a very popular test
for convergence or divergence which is
called the integral test
let me just write that down just so you
know what this is kind of the mental
foundations for
so what do i mean here so
let me write this sum again let me write
it a little bit different so
our original series from n equals 1 to
infinity of 1 over n squared
it's going to be equal to this first
block the area of this first block
plus the area of all of the rest of the
blocks the 1 4 plus 1 9 plus 1 16 which
we could write which we could write as
the reduce in a new color
which we could write as the
sum
from n equals 2
to infinity
of 1 over
n squared so i just i just kind of
express this as a sum of this plus all
of that stuff
now what's interesting is that this
this what i just what i just wrote in
this blue notation that's this
block
plus this block plus the next block
which is going to be less than this
definite integral right over here this
definite integral it notice it's an
underestimate it's always below the
curve so it's going to be less than that
definite integral so we can write that
this thing is going to be
less than
1 plus instead of writing this i'm going
to write the definite integral
1 plus the definite integral from 1
to infinity of 1 over
1 over x squared
dx
now why is that useful well we know how
to evaluate this i encourage you to
review the section on him on khan
academy on improper integrals if this
looks unfamiliar but i'll evaluate this
i'll evaluate this down here we know
that this is the same thing as the limit
as i'm going to introduce a variable
here t
approaches infinity of the definite
integral from 1 to t of and i'll just
write this as x to the negative 2
dx which is equal to the limit
as t approaches infinity
of
let's see the of
negative x to the negative 1 or actually
i could write that as negative 1 over x
negative 1
over x we're going to evaluate that as t
and at 1 which is equal to the limit
as t approaches infinity
of negative
1 over t
and then minus negative 1 over 1 so that
would just be plus 1 and as t approaches
infinity this term right over here is
going to be 0 so this is just going to
simplify to 1.
so this whole thing
evaluates to 1.
so just like that we were able to place
an upper bound on this series we're able
to say that the series
under question or in question
so the infinite sum from n equals one to
infinity of one over n squared is going
to be less than
one plus one or it's going to be less
than
it's going to be let me do this in a new
color
it's going to be less than it's going to
be less than 2. or another way to think
about it's going to be the 2 is this
area that's 1 right over there plus this
area right over here so we're saying
that this sum is going to be less than 2
so we have bounded it above so we know
it cannot go to positive infinity
because all the terms are positive it's
definitely not going to go to negative
infinity and because all the terms are
positive we also know that this isn't
going to oscillate between two different
values so this gives us a pretty good
sense
that this series is or that this series
converges
and the logic we just used here the
logic we just used here to argue for why
this converges once again not a rigorous
proof but this is the underlying logic
of the integral test